[Música]
Sean bienvenidos a este especial de
France 24 sobre Centroamérica un espacio
donde hablaremos del auge del
autoritarismo en algunos de los
gobiernos de la región una tendencia que
lleva años gestándose en naciones como
Nicaragua El Salvador o Guatemala pero
que ha incrementado especialmente en
este 2022
iniciamos hablando del Salvador el
presidente nayib bukele llegó al poder
en 2019 con la imagen de ser un político
moderno y antiestablecimiento pero
durante estos años su gobierno ha ido
captando poco a poco las instituciones
del estado algo que se ha agravado desde
marzo de 2022 cuando bajo el pretexto de
combatir la violencia de las maras el
mandatario decretó un estado de
excepción que se prolonga hasta la
actualidad en el siguiente informe
repasamos lo vivido en El Salvador
durante estos más de ocho meses en los
que se ha ejercido un poder casi
absoluto
la imagen de militares desplegados en
las calles del Salvador es habitual
desde hace más de ocho meses esto tras
un estado de excepción decretado por el
presidente nayib bukele Para combatir a
las pandillas la crisis de seguridad en
el país estalló después de que entre el
25 y el 27 de marzo fueran asesinadas 87
personas hechos que sirvieron como
detonante para que bukele recrudeciera
su guerra contra las maras a un nivel
nunca antes visto detenciones masivas y
métodos cuestionados por violar los
Derechos Humanos Se volvieron algo común
en total
a los que los tenemos sin colchonetas
durmiendo en el suelo fascinados con dos
tiempos de comida y es importante que
sepas que si se tratan de pasar de vivos
vamos a bajar de dos tiempos a cero
tiempos de comida y vamos a ver cuánto
tiempo dura el argumento del mandatario
es que las maras solo se pueden
enfrentar con mano dura pero esta
política ha llevado a torturas
hacinamiento carcelario y violaciones a
los Derechos Humanos según Human Rights
watch más de 58.000 personas fueron
detenidas en estos meses dentro de las
cuales también hay un número
indeterminado de inocentes que el
enfoque es siempre en los derechos de
los delincuentes y la gran mayoría de la
gente honrada
nadie le importan sus derechos numerosas
familias denuncian detenciones
arbitrarias a personas solo por llevarte
tatuajes o resultar sospechosos
a mi niño aquí para mí no es fácil pero
le pido a Dios que Dios Tenga
misericordia no solo de mi hijo sino de
muchos inocentes que están ahí tras
meses de estado policial la criminalidad
ha descendido en El Salvador pero aunque
el gobierno sostiene que estos casos son
el 1% las cifras reales podrían ser
mucho más altas para ampliar más todo lo
desarrollado quiero dar la bienvenida a
Valeria Vázquez analista especializada
en Centroamérica de control risk Muchas
gracias por estar en France 24 Valeria
Muchas gracias por la invitación
Valeria en El Salvador los índices de
violencia al inicio del gobierno de
nayib bukele fueron relativamente bajos
Pero esto cambió a finales de marzo por
qué incrementó tan abruptamente la
violencia en este país Valeria
Cómo mencionas justamente a finales de
marzo vimos en el último fin de semana
como se registraron 87 homicidios a
nivel nacional algo nunca antes visto y
mucho se ha dicho de una posible tregua
entre el gobierno de nayib bukele con
las principales pandillas la Mara
Salvatrucha y la y la barrio 18 y esto
no es algo nuevo esto es una política
una estrategia que muchos gobiernos
anteriores a bukele han optado para
disminuir los niveles de violencia en el
país sin embargo hablando un poco más
adentrándonos un poco más al gobierno de
nayib bukele hay muchas pruebas que han
publicado medios independientes
de funcionarios públicos allegados a
bukele
entrando a cárceles del país hablando
con líderes
hay audios hay videos hay fotografías
hay muchas pruebas Y probablemente lo
que sucedió en marzo fue que La tregua
salió mal fue que probablemente
un una de las pandillas pidió algo y el
gobierno no hizo caso no se dieron las
concesiones prometidas a las pandillas y
y por eso fue que vimos eso
bueno Está la situación con respecto al
Salvador pero también otra de las
naciones que lleva años Sufriendo
represión y violación de derechos es
Nicaragua el gobierno de Daniel Ortega y
Rosario Murillo ha consolidado todavía
más su poder en este 2022 además de
considerar ilegales a decenas de ongs
han intensificado la persecución contra
miembros de la Iglesia Católica varios
religiosos han sido víctimas del
gobierno de Ortega unos han sido
capturados mientras otros se han visto
obligados a huir del país por las
represalias de este gobierno en la
siguiente informe queremos ampliar lo
vivido en Nicaragua en este año 2022
las relaciones entre la Iglesia Católica
y el gobierno de Ortega han sido tensas
desde las manifestaciones de 2018 de
hecho el gobierno acusa a la iglesia de
querer desestabilizar al estado algo que
ha llevado a que el obispo Rolando
Álvarez uno de sus líderes fuese
detenido en agosto Pues el gobierno
siempre ha pretendido una iglesia muda
no quiere que hablemos no quiere que
anunciemos la esperanza al pueblo ni
denunciemos la injusticia en marzo la
crisis incluso provocó la expulsión del
embajador del Vaticano monseñor gol de
marzo martag a la que se sumó la de la
embajadora de la Unión Europea en
septiembre poco antes de que Nicaragua
también rompiera sus relaciones
diplomáticas con Países Bajos aislando
aún más al país centroamericano y el que
viene aquí
a faltarle el respeto a nuestro pueblo a
nuestra patria pues que no vuelva a
aparecer por Nicaragua este año cientos
de organizaciones no gubernamentales
fueron prohibidas por el régimen
Ortega que gobierna con su esposa sin
interrupciones desde 2007 está acusado
de implementar una dictadura familiar en
el país las últimas elecciones
municipales tuvieron sin compañía
electoral y sin oposición política no
hay libertad de reunión libertad de
movilización libertad de prensa libertad
de expresión y la digamos que el punto
más visible de este de esta represión es
la existencia de más de 225 presos
políticos entre tanto la situación del
periodismo está entre las peores del
planeta el índice de libertad de prensa
de reporteros Sin fronteras ubica al
país en una zona roja ya que se
encuentra en el puesto 160 de 180
naciones que hacen parte de la lista los
periodistas viven bajo censura
intimidación y detenciones arbitrarias y
muchos de ellos han optado por el exilio
para proteger sus vidas
bueno en este punto Me gustaría volver
con Valeria para hablar sobre Nicaragua
Valeria hemos visto que en este 2022 el
gobierno de Ortega y Rosario Murillo han
atacado con especial fuerza a la iglesia
católica Por qué
Porque hasta el momento la Iglesia
Católica había sido la única voz crítica
que rechazaba tanto las violas centros
de Derechos Humanos la persecución
política religiosa los abusos de poder
de Ortega de Murillo Y por qué porque
las organizaciones de sociedad civil
opositores la prensa independiente ya
estaba en el exilio presa o callada
porque tenía miedo entonces la iglesia
católica quedó como el único actor con
voz crítica y y básicamente lo que ha
hecho Ortega y murió a formar una una
campaña mucho más amplia para silenciar
a la iglesia católica a la que también
en su tiempo en el 2018 los acusaron de
de
apoyar la crisis desde entonces y
digamos que va está estos ataques van
incrementando se ha visto en los últimos
meses y al final la Iglesia Católica es
el último bastión que le quedaba a a
Nicaragua para para un tanto luchar
contra La dictadura o contra la política
de Ortega y Murillo y pues bueno ahora
sí está un poco está un poco es poco
probable que esto mejore
durante estos años hemos visto además
que este gobierno ha atacado ngs a la
prensa a opositores te quería preguntar
se está convirtiendo Daniel se está
convirtiendo Daniel Ortega en un
dictador similar al que fue Anastasio
somoza también en Nicaragua precisamente
un personaje contra él que él mismo
luchó y logró derrocar
de hecho creo que se está convirtiendo
en alguien Sí igual o incluso peor que
Anastasio somoza estamos viendo como
muchos de los de los de los individuos
que ayudaron al propio Ortega A derrocar
a anasta fueron encarcelados otros están
exiliados por miedo y y digamos que esto
es una es un tipo de represión muy muy
muy que va incrementando cada vez más en
cambio en en la dinastía de anasta
veamos un poco un tinte es un poco más
digamos un poco más tranquilos en cuanto
a la represión sin embargo un Ortega no
estamos viendo eso y tampoco estamos
viendo que que haya actores tanto
locales e incluso internacionales que
puedan derrocar esta Dinastía que
también está Daniel Ortega con su
familia con su esposa con sus hijos en
puestos públicos entonces me atrevería a
decir que sí este es igual incluso peor
que Anastasio
bueno hemos de las violaciones a los
derechos en Nicaragua Pero también hay
un país en Centroamérica que sufre este
tipo de de casos alarmantes de
retrocesos en la libertad de prensa ese
país es Guatemala ya que bajo el
gobierno de Alejandro llámate el país ha
pasado de ocupar el puesto 124 a 180 en
libertad de prensa debido al incremento
de la persecución hacia medios y
periodistas críticos y el ejemplo más
claro es la detención en agosto del
periodista José Zamora director del
periódico por supuesta malversación de
fondos tras meses de persecución El
golpe definitivo hacia este periodista
llegó cuando publicaron unas
investigaciones en las que se acusaba a
yamatei y a su entorno de corrupción
entonces para finalizar quiero abordar
con Valeria la situación que se está
viviendo en Guatemala en este momento
está siguiendo esta nación los pasos que
tiempo atrás siguió Nicaragua es la
primera pregunta que te quiero realizar
y además Cuál es la razón de esa per de
yamate y hacia la prensa Valeria
Sí en los últimos meses bueno incluso
desde que Alejandría matriz llegó al
poder y ganó las elecciones en 2019
hemos visto un poco gradualmente como el
gobierno ha intentado silenciar a las
voces críticas una de ellas es la prensa
otros desde el sistema independiente
judicial que existía en su momento hoy
en día el sistema judicial es uno de los
principales digamos Blancos del gobierno
para silenciarlos y que no persigan la
corrupción de los funcionarios públicos
Entonces digamos que la prensa se ha
convertido la presencia independiente se
ha convertido en esta voz que que para
publicar
los miles de de casos de corrupción que
han salido a la luz que involucran tanto
allá maté y como a sus allegados
cercanos y y creo que hoy en día y
viendo lo que le viene a Guatemala el
próximo año con las elecciones
presidenciales podemos ver de que es
poco probable que que el postura de
yamaté con la prensa cambie Así que es
poco probable que que sea o que sea una
voz importante para esta lucha en
Guatemala bueno Valeria Vázquez
Muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
France 24
Muchas gracias Con esto llegamos al
final de este especial sobre la
situación política en estos países de
Centroamérica gracias a Gabriel callseng
por su labor en la edición y producción
del programa y recuerden seguir con
nosotros en France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]